by the way speaking of anti-semitism and
Trump Donald Trump has appointed Steve
Bannon as White House chief strategist
now this is a totally abortive decision
Steve Bannon the executive chairman of
Breitbart news who became the CEO of the
Trump campaign or the Chairman I don't
remember exactly what word was
ultimately used you but CEO heavily
associated with the anti-semitic
alt-right movement which we will be
profiling in detail next week I think
you'll learn a lot about that movement
but next week on yesterday morning CBS
Face the Nation program Gingrich was
asked by John Dickerson to respond to an
essay which said you know there's these
fringe anti-semites who are really
supporting Trump's rise to the White
House and now you're taking Steve Bannon
a guy who's tied in with Breitbart and
the alt-right and significant an Tyson
and anti-semitic movements isn't this a
really bad sign and Newt Gingrich this
is just amazing he defended he rejected
the idea that Bannon is anti-semitic by
using anti-semitic stereotypes you can't
write this stuff let's take a look at
the video here we're on the anniversary
of Kristallnacht which is the night when
the Nazis attack Jewish businesses and
I'm thinking about me what is yeah this
is crazy
yeah Donald Trump is a mainstream
conservative who wants to profoundly
take on the left the left is infuriated
that anybody would challenge the
legitimacy of their moral superiority
and so the Left gives hysterical but the
fact is you know and you get this with
all these smears of Steve Bennett Steve
Brennan is a naval officer he was a
managing partner Goldman Sachs he's a ha
he was a Hollywood movie producer you
know the idea that somehow he represents
I'd never heard of the alt-right until
the nut case started writing about it
but so your point is it's garbage
therefore Donald Trump doesn't have to
deal with that it has to be Donald Trump
so Steve Bannon can't be anti-semitic
because he worked in two industry
stereotypically associated with Jewish
control he worked for Goldman Sachs an
investment banking firm and Jews founded
that and of course Jews control
Hollywood so so this guy can't be ant
Semitic see otherwise the cabal's of
Jews running those industries would
never have allowed Bannon in this is
more acceptable when it's Jews because
imagine if the question was bias against
black people and Newt Gingrich said
Steve Bannon oh no no no he's not anti
black he worked on a watermelon farm and
at Kentucky Fried Chicken oh okay we'll
consider me corrected Pat Steve Bannon
is not any uh anybody we should be
concerned with in terms of policy or
ideas towards towards black or sentiment
that's the equivalent of what is being
said it's just more acceptable when it's
smooth talking Gingrich talking about
finance and hot excuse me and Hollywood
yeah I think Newt Gingrich actually made
some of these comments subconsciously
right you tried to legitimize Steve
Bannon as more than just an alright
editor right uh finance and uh Hollywood
ties so so we'll see it's concerning is
it's very disturbing and and this is not
by the way the all the Steve Bannon
stuff is not without a basis court
documents from 2007 revealed that his
ex-wife Mary Louise Picard said Bannon
didn't want their daughters going to a
particular school in Los Angeles because
there were just a lot of Jews that went
there he also stated according to his
ex-wife that he doesn't like Jews and he
doesn't like the way that they raised
their kids and this has been an
explosion we earlier in the show I told
you about the anti-semitic hate mail I
received Southern Poverty Law Center
receiving two hundred-plus complaints of
anti-semitic vandalism or or incidents
related to anti-semitism this type of
thing mark my words will be attempted to
be normalized by individuals like Steve
Bannon and the alt writers and we've got
a big expose on them coming up on uh
Monday